Geht es nach Elon Musk werden wir Menschen
den Mars schon ziemlich bald besiedeln können.
Doch um diese irre Vision Wirklichkeit werden
zu lassen, stehen uns noch einige Herausforderungen
bevor.
Und da mischt auch die NASA mit.
Durch einen Ideenwettbewerb, den die US-Weltraumbehörde
ins Leben gerufen hat, sollen die Pläne für
eine Mars-Besiedlung konkreter werden.
Die Fragen lauten: Wie könnte eine nachhaltige
Unterkunft für zukünftige Mars-Bewohner
aussehen und wie genau könnten Häuser auf
dem Roten Planeten gebaut werden?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Elon Musk will ja nicht nur der erste sein,
was den Transport zur ISS betrifft, was ja
durch eine Explosion der Crew Dragon zurückgeworfen
wurde.
Im letzten Video haben wir ja detailliert
darüber berichtet.
Er will auch der erste auf dem Mars sein.
Wir machen hier ja immer wieder Videos über
die super-ehrgeizigen Pläne von Elon Musk
zu einer zukünftigen Marsbesiedlung.
Derzeit ist sein Unternehmen “SpaceX”
ja mit dem Raumschiff “The Starship” beschäftigt,
das etwa 100 Menschen und rund 100 Tonnen
Fracht zum Mars bringen soll.
“The Starship” ist knapp 55 Meter hoch
und soll auf dem Raketenträger namens “Super
Heavy” in den Weltraum fliegen.
Denn geht es nach Elon Musk, kann lediglich
eine autarke Stadt auf dem Roten Planeten
das Fortbestehen der Menschheit sichern.
Doch nehmen wir mal an, alle Fragen und Unwägbarkeiten
zum Transport der zukünftigen Mars-Bewohner
wären gelöst und Menschen könnten tatsächlich
sicher zum Roten Planeten gelangen.
Die nächste Herausforderung wäre ja die
Unterbringung der Siedler, damit sie überhaupt
ein Dach über dem Kopf haben.
Um genau diese Fragestellung dreht sich ein
aktueller Ideenwettbewerb der NASA, der mit
einem gigantischen Preisgeld von rund zwei
Millionen US-Dollar, also umgerechnet etwa
1.800.000 Euro, dotiert ist.
Die US-Weltraumbehörde möchte damit Antworten
auf folgende Fragen bekommen: Wie könnte
ein Habitat auf dem Roten Planeten errichtet
werden?
Aus welchen Materialien könnten die Unterkünfte
bestehen?
Sind diese Materialien auf dem Mars selbst
zu finden oder müssten sie vor Ort 3D-gedruckt
werden?
Die Vision der NASA ist es, einen 3D-Drucker
zum Mars zu schicken und bereits im Vorfeld
einen Lebensraum für die zukünftigen Mars-Siedler
zu errichten.
Der Wettbewerb selbst ist langfristig angelegt
und erstreckt sich über mehrere Jahre.
Jetzt hat die NASA aber die drei Finalisten
der “3D-Printed Habitat Challenge” ausgewählt.
Deren Computermodelle haben sich gegen acht
andere Teilnehmer durchgesetzt und zwar unter
anderem in den Bereichen Ästhetik, Aufbau
und Machbarkeit.
Auf Platz drei gelandet ist ein Team aus Connecticut.
Die designte Unterkunft namens “Mars Incubator”
besteht aus insgesamt vier Räumen.
Diese sind durch Brücken miteinander verbunden
und mit Streben auf dem Boden montiert.
Es handelt sich also um ein modulares Design,
wobei die Kugeln ein fußballähnliches Design
aufweisen.
Drei der vier verbundenen Kugeln sind für
das Zusammenleben und die Arbeit der Mars-Siedler
vorgesehen.
Hier können sie sich aufhalten, entspannen
oder sich im Labor mit Experimenten beschäftigen.
In dem vierten Raum mit fünf Fenstern könnten
Pflanzen angebaut werden, die beispielsweise
als Nahrung dienen.
Dieses Gewächshaus soll unabhängig von den
anderen Einheiten mit Süßwasser, einem Kühlsystem
und einer Art Heizung ausgestattet werden.
Die Materialien, die für den Bau des Mars-Inkubators
benötigt werden, sind alle auf der Mars-Oberfläche
vorhanden.
Beispielsweise Regolith, also Mars-Sand und
das darunter liegende Grundgestein aus Basalt.
Polyethylen dagegen kommt natürlicherweise
nicht auf dem Mars vor; kann aber laut der
Finalisten relativ einfach durch die Kombination
von Wasser und Co2 hergestellt werden.
Dieses Material eignet sich besonders gut,
um die kosmische Strahlung abzuschirmen.
Eine insgesamt wirklich spacige Konstruktion!
Auf Platz zwei gelandet ist das Team, das
sich “Zopherus” nennt und aus dem US-Bundestaat
Arkansas kommt.
Bei ihrem Design haben sich die Macher an
der Natur orientiert und zwar an dem Bau der
Bienen-Waben.
So sieht ihr Entwurf eine modulare wabenförmige
Bauweise vor.
Das Team schlägt vor, dass ihre kuppelförmigen
Häuser von einem mobilen Rover gedruckt werden.
Auch hier sollen zum einen private Räume
für die Crew-Mitglieder integriert werden,
zum anderen aber auch Laborräume zur Erforschung
des Mars’.
Auf Platz 1 gelandet ist das TeamSEArch+/Apis
Cor.
Ihr Design des “Mars House” zeigt einen
hohen zylinderförmigen Turm, der mehrere
Etagen beinhaltet.
So soll eine künstliche Erdatmosphäre geschaffen
werden.
An den Seiten und auf der Oberseite sind muldenförmige
Öffnungen vorgesehen, die Licht hineinfallen
lassen.
Auch hier sind natürlich zum einen private
und zum anderen dienstliche Räume für die
Siedler vorgesehen - verteilt auf den verschiedenen
Ebenen.
Als Material dient auch hier wieder unter
anderem Regolith und Polyethylen.
Alle drei Finalisten haben schon jetzt ein
Preisgeld von etwa 27.000 Euro bekommen.
In einem weiteren Schritt sollen sie jetzt
ein maßstabsgetreues Modell als 3D-Druck
entwickeln.
Schon bald (Mai 2019) soll dann der Sieger
bekannt gegeben werden, der noch einmal 700.000
Euro abstaubt.
Die NASA möchte die Ideen übrigens nicht
nur für eine zukünftige Mars-Mission nutzen,
sondern auch bezüglich einer möglichen Mond-Besiedlung.
Doch höchstwahrscheinlich ist zunächst einmal
der Mars anzupeilen.
Denn er ist aus verschiedenen Gründen tatsächlich
ein Planet, auf dem man sich Leben theoretisch
vorstellen kann.
Beispielsweise hat er zumindest eine dünne
Atmosphäre, die vor kosmischer Strahlung
schützt.
Zum anderen sind dort die Temperaturen hinnehmbar
und es gibt genug Sonnenlicht, das man nutzen
könnte.
Zudem ist der Tag-Nacht-Rhythmus auf dem Mars
dem der Erde sehr ähnlich: Ein Tag auf diesem
Planeten dauert 24 Stunden, 39 Minuten und
35 Sekunden.
China plant Mars-Kolonie - Da ist also auch
etwas im Gange - Draufklicken, anschauen und
natürlich Clixoom Science & Fiction abonnieren.
Und viele Fragen nach dem WhatsApp-Newsletter.
Dafür hier draufklicken.
Bis dann, bleibt dran.